hello gorgeous angel from heaven
i was excited oh thank you
um
one division i was so excited when you
came into
the universe because you were saying
things that i had been scratching my
head about watching the first four
episodes uh the first three episodes
is meant to kind of confuse and mystify
the audience so
finally somebody shows up to kind of
represent the audience and and tell them
more or less what's going on we think
uh so
i'm reprising a role i played in the
first two thor movies and
jack schaefer the writer
gave darcy my character a whole new life
and now she's you know she kind of
figures out the beginnings of this
mystery
and i commend everybody at the studio
for having frankly the spine to
have this mystery be unveiling
demand patience and create something
that isn't a spoon-fed journey where you
just know everything that's very rare
a hundred percent and also
it's a mystery till the end you know
there every episode is building and
building and building and
the
i i don't know really what happens but
there's a massive payoff for pretty much
everything in the show so
i encourage people to pay attention
while they're watching um i
love that you posted in um what was it
october a really thoughtful tweet uh for
billy eilish who is just i mean since
she's come on to the scene and we're all
freaking out on how amazing
uh she is and and and
you what was what was your support may i
ask
i love billy eilish anyway i was
obviously in a mood that day but you
know it's just that it's a young girl
like this is a child we're talking about
and i grew up and i know you certainly
grew up in a time where like you're just
scrutinized so much i mean this amazing
body positivity movement that's
happening now is amazing and awesome
but when i was younger you know that
this wasn't the way it was and i you
know i got a lot of
negative
talk about my body and i just kind of
like lived with it and
i'm sure it created a lot of
problems i'm sure it's why i'm kind of a
jerk now but um you know i just there's
something visceral that happens to me
when somebody
talks about a young person's body it's
not okay and it's none of their business
and this is a
person who has created the most
beautiful
like culture changing art
and this is what you taught it's so
stupid to me
i you know i just i loved hearing that
and
it's true we should all support each
other and that's exactly what you did
and i
i don't know billy eilish i would give
anything to no billy eilish
well or you could figure out a way to
have billy eilish on your show come on
um
but you also have a cat named millie
and you post about that every day your
social media is so cool that's my cat
peach
oh
wait they could be baby kitty sisters i
know i was thinking a
gorgeous baby
look at our two kitties together millie
and peach they look like soul sisters
oh
god you know i just every time i see her
i fall back in love again
um also you have an amazing hack for
opening cat food can you show us that
hack
listen if my career has led me to the
place where i open a can of cat food on
television um
so
uh i like to have fancy nails i do them
myself i have the little lamp and the
gel polish and the whole thing i taught
myself before the pandemic so it's
really come in handy
and i don't want to mess up my nails by
opening my beloved
cat's
cat food cans because i am a woman of
glamour
um
just kidding
and um so one day i was like i don't
wanna get a spoon and do this i don't
want to make a cat food spoon that's
annoying so i went and i got a little
barrette and you see this curve drew oh
i do
it goes like
perfectly
underneath the thing
listen i play a scientist on tv but also
i'm kind of one in real life
i mean look at this it saves the nail
and then you just pop
oh i'm not
thrifty and glamorous
um yeah
that's my hat wow i've made it i love
that
i love that hat cat i love it so much
now there is um something else that you
do that i immediately grabbed onto
and um
it's you've been gardening
yes
yes this is what uh this time has done
to me and i'm so passionate and you
garden as well i just started in the
beginning of the in sometime in around
march april i thought i'm gonna use this
time to do something i've always wanted
to do
[Music]
you